bonjour ahmed azirar merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
pour décrypter ces scrutins au maroc
trois scrutins en même temps aujourd'hui
expliquez nous en quoi c'est nouveau
bonjour bonjour à vos auditeurs alors
c'est des élections à spécifique dans la
mesure où pour la première fois elles
ont lieu de manière groupée il y à aussi
bien les législatives il ya également
dans les communes aller il ya les
régionales donc un système que la
constitution de 2011 donc elle a dix ans
aujourd'hui elle est assez mûr pour
passer un état supérieure d'application
alors ces régionales justement et ces
communales sont aujourd'hui vu comme
étant importante par tout le gotha
politique parce que justement les
affaires régionales dans les 12 régions
mais également les communes prennent du
poids de par la constitution et donc
tout le milieu politique accorde une
importance bien entendu le plus
important ce sont les législatives
puisque les deux chambres donc
aujourd'hui on va élire les membres de
la chambre des députés donc la chambre
des représentants et le 5 octobre
prochain il y aura l'élection de la
deuxième chambre donc qui complétera un
art mature donc du parlement par le mot
qui a pris un poids important de part
justement la constitution de 2011 qui
vous rappelez ces deux mille ans seiler
justement de ce qu'on appelait le
printemps à ras el maroc a dépassé
justement son heure cette phase assez
chahuté dans le monde arabe et à grâce à
cette justement constitution a permis de
passer la main donc d'organiser une
alternance politique qui a fait que les
islamistes en prix dû puiser dans les
islamistes modérés en prie pouvoir et
ils ont passé justement à la tête du
vers le mot une dizaine d'années
maintenant alors une dizaine d'années
qui a ses points forts mais aussi
beaucoup de faiblesses aujourd'hui et
c'est à ce niveau que les électeurs
aujourd'hui sont appelés à se prononcer
jusqu'au mans vous en parliez à
l'instant parmi les enjeux en l'avenir
du pjd le parti islamiste modéré quels
sont les autres candidats en lice
il ya aujourd'hui on peut dire donc il
n'ya pas malheureusement de ce sondage
officiel mais de quoi bien sûr les
signes que nous avons vu à travers aussi
vient donc ce qui se fait ce qui se
passe dans les rues mais surtout les
réseaux sociaux qui ont pris une ampleur
sans précédent avec la pandémie bien
entendu elle maroc dans sa globalité à à
changer de logiciel puisque le digital a
pris une place formidable donc aussi
bien au niveau administratif mais
également dans le pop alors à tout ça
montre justement que quatre partis
aujourd'hui émergent du lot alors il y a
naturellement le le pjd puisque il a été
aux commandes mais qui est chahuté il
faut le dire aujourd'hui nous l'avons vu
à travers ce qui s'est passé dans les
rues mais également à travers les
réseaux sociaux mais il ya également le
rassemblement national des indépendants
c'est un parti libéral aujourd'hui qui a
fait preuve d'une grande
un mobilisation qui a innové en matière
de campagne électorale il ya également
les sticks l'âme qui est un
parti traditionnel donc issu de la lutte
pour l'indépendance
mais il ya également le parti de
l'action un parti de l'action mais il ya
également le parti libéral également
qui a
été créée en 2008 et qui a
[Musique]
était dans une lutte assez assez
violente un certain moment avec les
islamistes mais qui aujourd'hui a signé
un peu une accalmie avec les islamistes
donc il ya un gros quatre parties qui
émergent du lot mais il ya également
qu'à deux parties à moyens alors
notamment
il nous reste peu de temps j'aimerais
qu'on parle quand même de l'abstention
qui est redouté et d'une campagne
électorale qui finalement n'a pas
beaucoup intéressé les marocains
on ne peut pas affirmer cela donc il y a
également des signes bien sûr qu'ils
font qu' il y aura une abstention
peut-être mais également nous avons vu
une forte mobilisation donc d'abord il y
a dix huit millions d'électeurs donc
c'est beaucoup plus que dans en 2016 il
ya également trois millions de jeunes
qui se sont inscrits donc ça prouve
également que il y a une possibilité que
ce taux d'abstention ne soit pas aussi
fort qu'on le craint donc la
participation en 2016 a été de 43 %
alors les partis tous les partis
pratiquement d'appeler et de manière
forte les électeurs à venir de choisir
ce qu'ils veulent mais de voter et ça
c'est quelque chose qui a été
particulièrement vue il a été échangé
par tout le gotha politique
merci beaucoup ahmed azirar pour votre
éclairage je le rappelle vous êtes
économiste coordinateur d étude du think
tank institut marocain d'intelligence
stratégique
merci à vous